[Music]
um it feels really magical and I feel
like slowly I'm just like absorbing
really what this is and what this means
and it's amazing it's really great
um you know Samira said that not only
has been waiting a few years to just
have to expect
something like this
absolutely like I feel like a lot of
people when they're hearing about the
Legacy Awards is like oh my God we
really haven't had anything like this
like how is that possible but I'm so
happy that it's them I feel like it's
gonna be so fun and this is really going
to be amazing so much of this evening is
about inspiration right the people
watching will be inspired to say you
know what maybe I can do that too
oh my gosh I feel like there were so
many one of the main ones I do music as
well as acting and seeing Beyonce and
like her passion and drive and like just
giving everything to her art and to what
she believes in that was a really big
inspiration for me I love her and
definitely XOXO what his Gossip Girl
life been like for you yeah
um honestly like a dream for truly a
fantasy I like wear beautiful clothes
all the time we go to all like the hot
spots in New York and like anywhere so
um I couldn't even imagine a better job
to be honest like it causes a lot of
hurts and what can you see me
[Music]
um it's very very dramatic as I'm sure
you can imagine there's lots of
beautiful fashion we go to Italy at the
end so that's going to be like a really
fun twist there like literally all the
things just all of the things like
everything good that's what you can
expect awesome thank you yes